(rock music)
- Hi!
- What a nice place!
What's that?
- Oh, it's just the kid.
This is your guncle Curly.
- A Homosexual uncle, I like to suck--
(guitar riff)
- Kung Fu Panda 3?
We'll take two for The Revenant.
Glen!
Hey, run down to the uh,
corner store and get me
some toilet paper, will ya?
Five more minutes.
The park doesn't close!
When I hand this behind
my back after I get in,
okay, it's going to be fine, just--
- You can't bring a kid in here.
- Oh no that's not a kid,
that's my cousin who has a very rare,
uh, bone disorder.
- That's a kid.
- Gotta do something
with it or put it away.
Hey no no no no!
I said two parts removed,
what are you doing?
Do you remember what I said?
Next time kick him in the nuts,
call him a (bleep) and run.
(vomiting)
It's just uh, bad sushi.
Thank you, here hold this.
Thank you. You too.